bonsoir à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport tout de
suite on passe au sommaire handball
féminin montigny le bretonneux a
remporté une précieuse victoire sur son
terrain contrôle dreux les filles de
philippe étrange se sont imposé 33-22
tous les détails dans cette édition
rugby les championnats touchent à leur
fin nous pour un point complet sur les
club yvelinois nous recevrons sur ce
plateau l'entraîneur de chevaux aubry
strunc kong il relève du club rugby club
de versailles antoine bloody de plaisir
et julien ma mère de la smb rugby bmx la
coupe de france de la discipline et est
organisée ce week-end au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
coup de projecteur sur la compétition
dans ce set 8 sport et puis en fin
d'émission nous reviendrons sur tous les
résultats sportifs du week end dans le
département
on commence le journal sport par la très
belle victoire de montille bretonneau
handball féminin les filles de philippe
étrange se sont imposés 33 à 22 sur leur
terrain sur l'euro l' dans leur salle
face à dreux
le montage est signée roma house fini
une véritable bouffée d'oxygène les
joueuses de montigny le bretonneux qui
restait sur trois défaites consécutives
ont étrillé dreux 33 à 22 sur leur
terrain une victoire avec la manière qui
permet à l'équipe de se rassurer dans ce
championnat de nationale 2 cette
victoire je pense qu'elle a mérité
on a eu une période assez difficile à
ces derniers temps
notamment trois défaites ça nous a mis
un peu la tête dans le seau donc il
fallait absolument gagner ce soir et je
pense qu on le fait avec la manière
burlesque arsenal avec 33 points
inscrits sur ce match lésigny montée
n'ont une nouvelle fois prouvé leur
force offensive penalty tirs sur les
ailes shoot à mi distance les vertes ont
fait le spectacle devant leurs
supporters c'est notre jeu généralement
en début de période de première mi-temps
on donne tout ce qu'on a on a une
période où
on baisse un peu
en intensité malheureusement ça arrive
toujours cours de la 15e 20e minute mais
bon on a su relever la tête donc c'est
le principal mais c'est vrai qu'on
essaye d'être très incisif dès le départ
à la proche de la première mi temps et
au début de la deuxième grâce à ce
succès les inhumant ten compte désormais
39 points à cinq journées de la fin du
championnat
au classement montigny le bretonneux
rejoint le troisième
aubervilliers la suite cdc gagné les
cinq matches qui restent
et puis espérer que les autres
s'entretuent voilà il faudrait dire un
concours de circonstances intéressante
pour nous mais pourquoi pas tous les
matches vont être difficiles
il va y avoir beaucoup de danger parce
que les points sont à prendre et on peut
plus se permettre de perdre donc on n'a
plus droit à l'erreur
jusqu'à la fin de la saison prochain
match pour les inhumant tel le samedi 11
avril contre bové la victoire est
impérative pour montigny le moindre faux
pas pourrait être fatale dans la course
à la montée en nationale une
après laurent bàn nous passons
maintenant au rugby nous reviendrons
coup de projecteur sur les performances
des clubs yvelinois
nous avons du beau monde pour parler
rugby autour de cette table des
résultats notamment d'eric club
yvelinois
nous recevons donc sur ce plateau brice
trân trong donc coach de chevreuse
oui guillaume nero 9 entraîneur de
l'équipe de versailles antoine bloody
second ligne aux plaisirs b-club et
julien ma mère est liée à l' smb
montigny alors on commence tout de suite
donc par la belle performance de
chevreuse
donc il s'est imposé hier 7 à 3 contre j
x donc conséquence le club termine
premier de sa poule alors j'imagine que
vous êtes très heureux après s'être un
pont heureux heureux et fatigué on est
fatigué on là il est arrêté on l'a bien
fait et nous dans une saison d'une
saison n'a été produit et où le temps
s'est vraiment fait peur là sur cette
fin de saison avec la défaite de la
semaine dernière mais la voilà battre le
voisin j fois à la maison et se
qualifier pour la fédérale 3 c'est
parfait ça a été un match compliqué
ouais c'était c'était pas beau niveau
rugbystique mais une grosse grosse
intensité
les mecs ont rien lâché voilà victoire
sur le fil à la fin donc c'était sur la
dernière action un patois et maul porté
les mêmes pour 317 7 minutes 67e minute
donc qui vous offre donc la victoire
exactement et donc olivier neyreneuf
donc vous suivez avec assiduité donc
tous les résultats des clubs yvelinois
donc est-ce que vous pensez que cette
première place de chevreuse et méritait
bien sûr mais ça qu'elle a mérité
chevreuse et à mon avis dans les
yvelines un club qui doit arrêter et
veut aller en fédérale 3 de par leur
alors leur école de rugby leurs jeunes
qui fonctionne pas mal et il ya une
histoire et que cheuvreux est ce qui
fait qu elle doit être en fédérale 3
donc je serais très content de pouvoir
leur trouver une prochaine en fédérale 3
j'espère pour de nouveau derby en train
de l'audi vous avez connu donc la montée
l'année dernière avec plaisir comment on
est psychologiquement donc dans les
dernières mais dans les derniers matchs
sur la dernière ligne droite on et
comment psychologiquement quand on peut
accéder à la montée c'est à dire qu'on
est on est proche de l'euphorie mon l'a
pas encore on aura ces derniers matches
et c'est souvent pas évident parce qu'on
a peur de vouloir bien faire
du coup des fois ça s'approche des
matches un peu brouillon sépare
justement ne sais pas trop quoi faire on
n'en voit pas trop de jeu donc
félicitations à l'heureuse pour s'être
montré qu'il méritait et voilà ils ont
surréagi à face à ces pièces de gif
après avoir fait un petit faux pas face
à paris 15 mai ils méritent largement
leur montée en fédérale 3 et qu'est ce
qu'on ressent justement quand on a enfin
cette cette première place en poche
du coup on sans couac enfin vous avez
ressenti quoi plaisir bas nous ça
faisait un moment qu'on veut qu'on était
sur une sur une lancée on enchaînait les
phases finales on n'arrivait pas passer
des tours donc c'est vrai pour le coup
quand on a réussi à avoir cette honte en
fédérale 2 c'est eh oui c'était une joie
indescriptible c'était c'était vraiment
exactement j'étais on en pouvait c'était
c'était génial
brice c'est plus un soulagement quand
coup de sifflet final retentit où c'est
où on se projette déjà sur têt la saison
prochaine où on on préfère peut-être
savourer
dans un premier temps un soulagement
surtout en tant qu'entraîneur et puis
c'est compliqué une saison en tant
qu'entraîneur on peut plus se défouler
sur le terrain comme quand on était
joueur c'est frustrant c'est voilà on
est bord du ruhl serre et puis quand ça
se termine et qu'on sait que le travail
a été fait voilà on relâche tout et on
est content et puis bah on pense en
phase finale et puis on pense à la
fédérale 3 faux faux cyr a motivé le
groupe voit la fois faire plein de
choses et puis la saison est encore
longue mine de rien donc voilà un peu
les deux faut se remobiliser vite
maintenant je viens ma mère vous votre
coach cyril mûri et donc à entraîner à
l'équipe de chevreuse est-ce qui vous en
a parlé de cette équipe est ce que enfin
vous vous est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est un club qui peut qui peut
prétendre à la fédérale 3 mêmes visées
peut-être un peu plus haut que la
fédérale 3 sur les prochaines années
oui c'est un c'est un club qui depuis
depuis quand même des années fait fait
son petit bonhomme de chemin et shirin
nous en a pas vraiment parlé mais sans
qui la gare il a quand même l'amour de
ce club vraiment au fond nuque et donc
l'année prochaine aux visées gouzy quoi
c'est quoi c'est le médecin vous visez
vraiment à brice alors produit en prenez
objectif le maintien
après on verra tout est possible mais la
fédérale 3 ces relevés très relevé a
priori même voilà sa demande ça demande
énormément d'investissement des joueurs
du club des entraîneurs ça demande un
brin de réussite sa demande plein de
choses donc on verra on verra mais le
maintien en premier objectif
guillaume bref justement ce palier est
ce qu'il est si dur que ça à franchir il
ya un fossé vraiment entre la division
honneur et la fédérale 3 il ya un fossé
entre chaque division aujourd'hui
vraiment le plaisir pour en parler aussi
à face entre chaque division et même la
fédérale 3 d'aujourd'hui c'est la
fédérale 2 il ya cinq ou six enfin
vraiment les niveaux le niveau est enfin
c est vraiment très relevé
comme le nerd aujourd'hui plus élevé
qu'à l'époque mais ça reste quand même
on sent comme que les équipes sont armés
différemment plus on monte de division
plus son armée avec des budgets du club
dans la première fois des budgets d'aidé
certains clubs qui sont faramineux pour
des divisions comme la communauté par
rapport à nous quoi l'habit noir
j'ai pas envie dire petit club génois
mais presque on va dire et c'est dur
c'est bien surtout fait la différence
surtout sur l'impact physique et surtout
sur les gabarits des joueurs devant
enfin je peux pas fait d'arrêt lorsque
tu en penses
en fédérale 3 ça joue aussi là dessus
mais je trouve donc à chevreuse de sacs
de s'équiper
surtout devant je pense pour pouvoir
se maintenir est peut-être un peu plus
si affinités je sais que ça joue sur des
détails des matches qu'on perd d'un
point qu'on gagne d'un point ça peut
faire la différence à la fin de saison
quoi il ya également un match qui était
très important ce week end c'est le
match de plaisir donc vous avez gagné
votre match donc que contre vierzon
quatorze à dix c'était un match vraiment
compliqué oui c'est un match compliqué
on avait une équipe de vierzon en face
qui restait sur une saison blanche
aucune victoire et qui a donc une saison
très longue pour eux que ça soit en
terme de résultats sportifs ou même en
interne
c'était une équipe qui avait à coeur
donc de nous battre ce dimanche et qui
restait donc sur votre cette victoire
qu'on avait fait chez eux un peu à la
dernière minute en monte en 2e mi-temps
donc un match très très engagé très
brouillon avec des conditions
climatiques pas évidente beaucoup
beaucoup de vent donc a pas beaucoup de
jeu déployé on entrait très rugueux
voire trop rugueux parfois et donc non
le on retiendra la victoire ce week-end
qui est ce qu'on a notre objectif en
donner à vous reste à en venir dans ce
championnat de fédérale 2 oui tout à
fait oui je pense que aujourd'hui on est
très heureux d'avoir encore notre avenir
en main je pense que peu de gens envoyés
par et aurait parié là dessus en début
de saison et on a on s'est accroché on
est on a un groupe qui vit bien malgré
tout en interne
c'est ce qui fait notre force comme on
l'a dit tout à l'heure le niveau entre
chaque division et c'est un palier
énorme et on a appris au fur et à mesure
de l'année on a engrangé d'expérience
pour aujourd'hui arrivé à à ce niveau et
pouvoir jouer notre match en finale de
chevreuse lutter pour le maintien il ya
encore peu de temps on y commet
psychologiquement dans ces derniers
matchs ces matches couperets pour le
maintien brest en train non moi je les
ai pas connu ce match là mais j'imagine
j'imagine que voilà sportivement c'est
sportivement c'est vraiment comment dire
on regarde les jouer on a envie de les
jouer on a envie de les jouer on a envie
de gagner on a envie de tout faire pour
son club et son maillot maintenant c'est
l'intention je préférais jouer la montée
que je jouais la descente clairement si
on joue les derniers enfin les premiers
de poule en fin de saison c'est
compliqué on sait qu'elles n'appliquent
et la pression on joue des équipes de
deux bras du ventre mou du du bas du
tableau c'est c'est plus jouable donc ça
reste la guerre et wake pour venir à
plaisir c'est vrai que je pense pas
grand monde les données je vous le
maintien comme ça mais quand même
connaissant un peu les plaisirs wap
réserve souvent ils ont une faculté de
guerriers surtout la maison que tout cas
moins que peu de clubs rouge trouver
goethe est sûr qu'ils allaient faire des
résultats la maison bien accrocher les
équipes du canard couche d équipe et
donc je pense que l'heure ce dernier
machado monde est justement ce dernier
match à domont donc c'est le 19 avril
c'est vraiment une finale en fait c'est
ça c'est vraiment vous gagnez vous
rester avoue rester dans ce championnat
de fédérale 2 vous perdez et vous
redescendez tout de suite c'est
exactement ça c'est le gagnant qui
croisent son ticket pour jouer la
prochaine en fédérale 2 donc on va on va
tout faire on a trois semaines pour se
préparer on voit en bas on va se
préparer à fond donc pour ce match et on
verra le 19 avril en tout cas on va on
va le jouer à fond va jouer le coup à
fond et jouer notre maintien jusqu'au
bout et le groupe le vit comment ce
match couperet
le groupe le vie je pense que on l'a
senti un peu ce week-end le groupe est
un peu un peu stressé content des
résultats de l'année mais veut vraiment
se maintient et c'est peut-être ça qui
nous a fait justement qui nous a déjoué
un peu ce week-end
ses proches de la correctionnelle face à
vierzon et voilà on va falloir se
libérer je pense que le goût qu'on est
capable et voilà on est aujourd'hui un
groupe très soudé c'est voilà si je
continue à dire cependant si tu es notre
force et on va jouer notre atout ce
dimanche je viens ma mère vous avez
connu aussi des matches couperets avec
les montigny on prépare commence ce
match vous par exemple vous avez après
par un dernier match
récemment comment vous l'avez préparer
ou quand vous les préparez ce match
sedan les matches vous pouviez vous
justement toi prétendre à la victoire
finale
déjà dans la semaine c'était difficile
pour nous parce qu on avait des soucis
d'effectif entre les jeunes avec leurs
études le travail pour certains donc
niveau de l'entraînement ça a été
vraiment très compliqué de préparer ce
match
après une fois qu'on est arrivés sur le
terrain ben on n'avait qu'une chose à
faire c'est ces jouets n'ont pas eu de
trop de stress justement pas avant le
match après pendant c'est il ya eu il ya
eu quand même un peu de stress plus que
sur le dernier match on a été mené au
score très rapidement
mais cette année on a comme on a réussi
à a évolué à reprendre le jeu à notre
compte
au fil de l'eau fil des minutes
guillaume 09
est-ce que ça serait un véritable
exploit que plaisir reste en fédérale 2
où penser justement qu'il avait les
armes pour déposer les armes jeudi
j'étais sûr qu'ils ont embêtés certaines
équipes ça c'était une évidence et je
pense que ce sera un exploit si en effet
s'ils se maintiennent et je serai très
malheureux de devoir jouer l'année
prochaine parce que d'une part on n'aime
pas jouer contre eux c'est toujours des
matches qu'on comme médiateur pour ne
pas qu'on n'aime pas jouer partout qu'à
versailles plaisir a souvent battu
versailles en fédérale 3 mais plus que
l' inverse et dont je leur souhaite
vraiment de rester en fédérale 2 parfois
tu te contentes de retrouver chômeur qui
ne réussissent plus d'être à temps merci
guillaume 09 alors on passe tout de
suite au bmx
la coupe de france de bmx était
organisée ce week-end au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
l'événement a réuni près de 400
participants une centaine de spectateurs
des détails avec williams elle et elodie
moine le vélo était encore une fois à
l'honneur ce week-end dans les yvelines
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines a reçu plus de
400 participants pour les deux premières
manches de la coupe de france de bmx
les pilotes qu'on courait sur deux jours
dans leur catégorie pour cette épreuve
qualificative pour les championnats du
monde c'est ma première course en élite
2 donc c'est toujours un petit plaisir
et puis aujourd'hui on roule sur la
butte à 8 m donc bon c'est une première
aussi c'est toujours plaisir si on n'a
pas cette occasion à tous les jours avec
une nouvelle piste réaménagée pour
l'occasion plus technique le vélodrome a
séduit les pilotes ce qui est un peu
compliqué aujourd'hui en plus c'est une
piste très dures techniquement et puis
en plus avec le vent le vent qui se lève
là ça devient vraiment les courses un
petit peu mélangé quoi elle elle a été
rénovée et elle est beaucoup mieux
puisque avant l'été jugé trop simple un
beau spectacle pour le public
majoritairement composé de passionnés
une occasion pour admirer les
performances des champions de cette
discipline
parce que aujourd'hui
beau championnat championnat donc on
sait en fait toute la coupe de france en
jeunes aujourd'hui parce que je roulais
ce matin en catégorie 19 24 et je reste
aussi tout l'après midi pour voir les
meilleurs plants nos silos de voir
rouler ça fait du bien
le champion national andré silva raflé
la première place en élite hommes
chez les femmes c'est mariana pajon qui
se hisse à la tête du podium pour les
troisième et quatrième manches de cette
coupe
rendez-vous en charente maritime le 11
et 12 avril
nous sommes de retour avec nos quatre
invités alors nous allons parler tout de
suite de montigny-le-bretonneux alors
montigny a terminé à une très belle
deuxième place en 1re série derrière
alfortville comment vous gérez vous
justement cette deuxième place vous
étiez au coude à coude avec alfortville
jusque jusqu'à la dernière journée
comment digel rouge justement cette
deuxième place est une déception
on va dire que c'est mitigé parce que on
a perdu le premier match de championnat
qui on a tiré c'est un peu comme un
boulet sur toute la saison mais après on
est on est quand même content de notre
saison parce que notre objectif c'était
de finir dans les trois premiers
et puis on finit quand même sur douze
victoires d'affilée
invaincu sur les phases retour invaincu
à domicile donc on va dire qu'on est
quand même assez content de ce point de
vue là et vous allez donc vous avez
perdu justement trois matches cette
saison
justement est ce qu a pas une part de
déception
là dedans disant qu' on pouvait
difficilement faire mieux oui on aurait
on aurait pu quand même faire mieux a
déjà sur le premier match
après bon c'était le temps que la
machine se met en route que les
automatismes arrive après on a on a
quand même mis en place notre jeu on
on a fait on a fait circuler le ballon
comme on sait faire plus on a un groupe
très très jeune donc c'est quand même
bien débrouillés surtout le restant de
la saison
justement le groupe est assez jeune est
ce que brice est ce que ça peut être
vraiment un souci quand on vise la
montée
ceci par rapport à l'expérience en fait
bon pour l'expérience des des montées
des descentes le fait de gérer le voilà
le stress c'est comme dans le milieu
professionnel c'est comme partout à
l'expérience l'expérience prime je pense
que voilà nous c'est ce qui nous a
manqué je pense la semaine dernière au
match contre paris 15 pour valider notre
ticket en f3 parce qu'avoir des anciens
dans le rugby c'est voilà il faut ça
cadre le truc c puis ça reste quand même
un sport de combat et c'est mieux
d'avoir du vieux roublard que du petit
jeune de 19 ans mais après on il faut un
mix des deux pour la condition physique
notamment mai mais oui non il faut il
faut des anciens appartiendrait tout ça
justement un guillaume 09 aussi à
versailles
vous avez un groupe quand même assez
jeune justement comment quand vous
cadrez ce groupe voulait laisser
vraiment vous devez plus est encadrée
justement où l'ailé c'est peut-être un
petit peu faire un peu un peu ce qu'ils
veulent et vous corriger ensuite à après
les défauts n'ont pas faim ne seront pas
ce qu'ils veulent c'est comme c'est un
groupe jeune certes mais qui est
vraiment une base solide qui vit
ensemble depuis très longtemps donc il
fallait
ils se connaissent bien ils savent
comment ça fonctionne maintenant c'est
vrai que ça fait comme des trois saisons
on se dit qu il manque quand même un ou
deux papas pour notamment devant pour va
franchir un cap ces faits pareils ça
fait trois ans qu'on se qualifiera pas
cette année mais fait trois roses
qualifie compères premier tour pas ce
qui manque c'est ces personnes minces et
ces joueurs là qui qui apporte un petit
plus sur les mâles couperet et voilà
donc
j'espère que un jour on les aura ou que
nos jeunes seront assez mature un jour
pour jouer ces matches de monter et à
les voir un peu plus haut touché un peu
la fédérale 2 quoi l'année prochaine
vous risquez de rencontrer chevreuse ou
est-ce que votre la même poule g
seulement les retrouvailles vous
appréhendé un petit peu ces
retrouvailles où justement vous êtes
plutôt content que je voudrais exercer
puissent se rencontrer à nouveau
appréhendé j'irai pas appréhendé parce
que ces sucres comme j'étais là ça fait
un déplacement pas très loin mais nos
annonces moi j'ai pas ça peut être un
derby ça repart en tout cas oui bon
après les derbys s'arrêter d'herbe
on monte ça en derby un petit peu mais
bon après les générations actuelles sont
bas ce jour - france au moins se dire
qu'il ya moins quand même des sanguines
et rapaces en ligne et aimé de il ya
moins de border services comme des
histoires dans six autres
même si c'est vrai que du coup ça tout
cas semaine d'avant le dommage claquant
deux choses où vous de plaisir là la
sauce monte un petit peu lamentable d'un
petit peu mais bon ça reste je pense
aujourd'hui des match sympa à jouer
cette année dernière on a je revenus
personnels machabert serait il me semble
la saison c'était plateau encore mais
ils viennent de perdre chez nous et du
coup descendre pour les fait descendre
c'est un peu le jeu c'est le jeu quoique
c'est toujours un peu embêtant de devoir
faire descendre un club va devoir faire
de son poison de 2,2 de gagner votre
incapacité paria plaisir ya deux trois
ans j'aurais de trois ans il ya 3 4 ans
vous êtes une par contre vous avez gagné
à versailles saveur il doit vous at il
maintenu soit d'énergie mais contre nous
et nous n'était pas content non pas
parce que plusieurs semaines elle parce
que vous avez perdu
merci en tout cas vous cas d'être passé
sur ce plateau tout de suite on passe
aux autres résultats du week end
c'était l'évènement du week-end à
voisins-le-bretonneux la ville a
organisé le championnat régional de
gymnastique à au centre sportif les
pyramides
une compétition qui a réuni 85 équipes
de toute l'île de france on écoute
pascal tessier le président du club de
gymnastique de voisins-le-bretonneux en
prélevant talent si les régionales
donc là on reçoit toutes les régions la
de l'ile-de-france donc à elle des
départements contre 95 77 93
la région ile de france et ensuite à bas
se défieront les équipes pour
on va dire les demi finales du
championnat de france donc ça fait
depuis de la cbi la saison qu'on
travaille à cette compétition pour la
réalisation avec différentes réunions du
bureau et puis la communication avec la
fédération pour le ratifier
une remise de récompenses accueille les
juges
handball masculin le chesnay raté une
bonne occasion de s'emparer de la tête
du championnat de nationale 3 les hommes
de yanis norbert se sont inclinés contre
lille à l'extérieur sur le score de 29 à
une défaite qui coûte très cher dans la
course aux premières places au
classement lille compte désormais trois
points d'avancé sur les chesnaysiens à
quatre journées de la fin du championnat
le ch est né n'a plus son destin entre
ses mains et devra compter sur une
contre-performance de lille pour
s'emparer de la première place toujours
handball versailles n'y arrive toujours
pas en nationale 3 les versets ils se
sont inclinés contre bois colombes à
domicile 25 à 26 leur dixième défaite en
18 journées dans ce championnat les
verse ayant beaucoup tenté mais ont une
nouvelle fois pêché dans la finition
pour l'emporter
du côté du classement verseille toujours
10e avec un point d'avancé sur l'avant
dernier falaise calvados les versailles
et se déplaceront justement sur le
terrain de falaise la semaine prochaine
pour un match qui s'annonce décisif pour
le maintien on passe au football grosse
prestation de trappes en promotion
d'honneur et saint quentinois ont fait
match nul à domicile contre les premiers
du classement chatou score final 2 buts
partout au classement trap est toujours
menacé de relégation les trappistes son
dixième du classement avec deux petits
points d'avancé sur la zone rouge
chatou de son côté conserve la première
place à la différence de buts le pecs et
quatrième de ce championnat de promotion
d'honneur
le rallye des gazelles a débuté mercredi
dernier dans le désert marocain après
six jours de compétition les deux
trappistes séverine sous l'oeil laurence
se battent à la pointe allen 69e place
dans la catégorie première participation
la plaisir oise laura laura boog année
devant son homologue yvelinoise elle est
actuellement à la 58e place du
classement la catégorie dominée par le
duo français stéphane guerry et karine
poisson en football américain les
templiers d'elancourt reçoivent les
molosses d'asnières ce samedi pour le
compte de la 5e journée du championnat
élite
victoire impérative pour les élans
courtois les templiers ont remporté
seulement un match depuis le début de la
saison
si vous voulez soutenir les illinois la
rencontre est programmée à 20h au
complexe sportif europe
enfin en football le chine et reçoit ce
dimanche à 15h carrière grésillons au
stade michaud en match en match en
retard des finésiens cinquième du
championnat son favori sur cette
rencontre contre les derniers du
classement
victoire obligatoire pour le chimique
qui peut encore espérer viser le podium
en fin de saison
pour cela l illinois doivent ans
porter tous leurs matches jusqu'à la fin
du championnat c'est la fin de ce sept
huit sports je vous retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine très
bonne soirée sur tv fils à la 78